ok let's get into audience questions for
the week first one is from Ryan who says
hey David what's the most efficient and
effective way to convince non voters to
vote you've been talking about the
importance of voting for 2020 but how do
we get people to actually do it
excellent question I've been saying 2020
can be won or lost on turnout alone so
how do we actually get people to vote
even if we understand that we're better
off convincing people to vote who
already agree with us then trying to
argue with and change the minds of
Trumpets you still have to figure out
how to get non voters to vote something
has kept them from voting in the past or
they weren't old enough in which case we
just have to explain to them it's now
time you're you're now old enough but
let's explore it for people who have
been old enough to vote for a while but
have not voted before
first of all resist the urge to just
shame and insult them I share with you
this disbelief quite frankly about why
why wouldn't you vote I mean voting is
not everything but voting is sort of the
starting point for being politically
engaged but it's really important if we
want results we don't really care about
whether they feel bad about not voting
or not as long as they vote ok so resist
the urge to insult people or to shame
them for not voting or to call them dumb
for not voting engage them on why they
haven't voted and importantly sympathize
with that ok if someone says to you I
don't vote because I don't think my vote
matters don't say that's stupid it does
matter and here is why say I understand
feeling that way especially because we
vote and vote and vote and it seems like
so much doesn't change so I totally
understand why you would feel that way
here's why I think it's important to
vote voting is inconvenient don't say
how stupid are you that you can't get it
together to just go over and vote say I
understand that I work I get it there's
lines you worry about do I have the
right documents or do I need any
documents or voter intimidation all this
stuff don't say that these concerns are
unfounded but then you have to really
make the case that not vote
isn't neutral that whatever your reasons
are for not voting you are participating
in the end result as much as voters are
by saying I'm choosing not to have a
voice and I'm going to let the people
who choose to vote have
disproportionately more power by direct
consequence of me not voting the younger
the person you're talking to is you
should also be making the case that they
by voting are going to make small
redirections to the future path of the
United States that will impact them for
way more years then older folks are
going to be impacted simply because on
average that are going to be alive for a
longer period of time and then maybe the
most important thing I found in getting
people to become engaged is not to
overly focus on the impact of their vote
alone because no matter what case you
make one vote is just one vote in the
end concede that their vote alone is not
going to be what fixes things but make
it clear that it's a starting point for
activism and only by doing the homework
that's required to be an informed voter
and actually going out and and voting
are you going to build the framework of
understanding of what's going on around
you that will then better position you
to be an activist for what's important
for you speak about policy if you
identify specific policy issues that are
up for debate or that could be
influenced significantly based on the
election you are discussing so if it's a
local election and traffic issues are
really important to them and there are
traffic decisions to be made or that
will be made by the victor of the
upcoming election focus on that and
focus on how that relates to them and to
their lives and then lastly use some
polite peer pressure without shaming
someone for not voting everybody's doing
it and trying to get some kind of
commitment about participating can
actually go a really really long way
without bullying people obviously but
some polite sort of light
peer pressure I found can also be
extraordinarily effective let me know
how you have succeeded at getting people
to vote and again the reason we're
talking about this is that 2020 anyone
of the 2020 Democratic contenders can
defeat Donald Trump on turnout alone but
it's not going to happen unless we
actually know how to get people out
there in voting